hi I'm RIA I'm a tasty producer as
always I've been challenged to take a
common food and make it fancy here today
it's rolls you must completely use the
food given you can only add to the food
you can buy whatever ingredients you
wish okay let's see what we have today
of course my drum rolls Lunchables I've
heard of it but I've never knew what he
is Andrew told me there is a one called
branch Abel come with me Motors not sure
if it's true or not just according to
the package it looked like records
ham and cheese it's this lunch I always
forget kids had smaller stomach so I
never had this before so let's try this
I thought it was block of cheese but
it's sliced and crackers and so it's
almost like kids cheese board it's fuzzy
okay that's good it might be challenging
because I have to use three components
but I think I have one great idea
as always I'm excited to make it fancy
here's what I got asparagus X chicken
breasts rosemary thyme fingerling
potatoes butter garlic parmesan cheese
orange juice and sparkling wine from the
pantry I got milk flour Dijon mustard
garlic powder and onion powder let's get
started make it fancy okay
I'm gonna begin with my potatoes I
already washed the potatoes its
fingerling potatoes it's one of my
favorite kind usually come with purple
color and like red skin three different
colors so I think it looks really cute
I'm gonna cut in half
yes it's my lady they came back from the
spa super sharp you know someone on
Instagram talk to me he took his car to
the car wash and he said took my lady to
the spa so everyone has their own lady
what's your lady's data with olive oil
when you're quoting something usually
you have to stop it's wicked if you
season weights to the spice forest
everything gets kind of washed off
usually it's my hand it's the best tool
to sprigs all rosemary thyme and if you
like for salt too big pinch
you're a new thought something you have
to solve super high so it's sprinkle
even if you too close you are only like
pointing at one so I transfer everything
to baking she cut side down so he get
crispy baked this in oven 425 Fahrenheit
for 20 minutes to 30 minutes so potatoes
are in the oven and I'm going to move on
to the chicken
I have plastic and aneisa and I cover
with another plastic over the chicken
and I have a secret weapon the Foehammer
do you know the name of food hammer me
Anya I have Miller and I'm gonna pound
chicken so this one has two sides this
is one is for like tenderizing me but
this part it's just like flat tuna
I don't want to make any mark so I'm
using this flat part so I'm going to
sprinkle one teaspoon of garlic powder
and one teaspoon of onion powder per
chicken breast and soul one big pinch
and I'm going to add half how can I fit
this it fits perfectly
Wow cheese
same thing amazing lunch of all its
metaphor this fits perfectly roll this
up and
kind of twist the end like candy kind of
want to make a cylinder shape and you're
gonna roll against the surface so it's
super tight and I'm going to type and
chicken rolls are done and I'm going to
rest this in the refrigerator for 20
minutes I'm going to make sauce
meanwhile do means garlic I'm using this
knife called PT knife
it's easy to cut small thing like
garlic's this is one of my ladies 2 tbsp
flour and 2 tbsp of butter so far smell
butter 1 and 1/2 cup of milk 1/8 cup of
mustard
so butter is melted I'm going to the
garlic add flour and whisk just like a
minute also slowly so this is very
similar cells called bechamel it's one
of the mother sauce in French cooking so
what you wanna do is keep whisking until
it thickens we are going to use 1/2 cup
of Parmesan cheese it's nice and thick
so I'm going to add some cheese and
Dijon mustard remove from the heat but
sauce is ready I'm going to set this
aside so for my next step I have flour
and egg wash I used for X and I'm going
to grind up some crackers
[Applause]
so you just want to grind up until fine
chicken is from the fridge and I'm gonna
start coating with flour egg and cracker
breadcrumbs so oil has to be 325 I'm
going for internal temperature 165
Fahrenheit if it doesn't reach the point
I'm going to finish off in oven
nice sound
okay so color looking really good here
so I'm going to take it off because I
don't want to learn and I'm going to
check the temperature
this one it's 153 this one is 114 so I'm
going to finish off in oven about 10
minutes and we will check the
temperature again
next we're gonna do asparagus 12 to the
stem it's a little bit fibery remove
those kind of tough part there too it's
to do it one eat when you're kind of
snapping and naturally snap stop / it's
fine or you can just cut the end and use
the peeler so I'm going to use 3 to 4
tbsp of water so what are its stop
bubbling up at asparagus and the leader
back on top so it's spins so you kind of
want to wait until all the water
evaporates call with olive oil and look
shiny and a little bit of green light
almost seasoned salt and pepper so as
far as looks down so I'm going to
transfer to the tray and move on to the
next step
chicken in that temperature reached 165
so I'm going to start plating all cheese
is losing this spiral looks great data
looks good - I'm so happy how it turned
her her lunchable it's not for lunch
lunch avoids four chicken cordon bleu
it's so good welcome Andrew thank you
yeah somewhere in here is hidden
something that would normally be
described as not fancy exactly they want
to try it
sure were you doing man I'm opening the
champagne like III way that I will pop
the champagne
[Music]
like it tastes really good there's the
ham component there's usually some
cheese in there oh is it Lunchables
restorations do you remember you told me
there it's a branch of offal
come with me mother you oh I said I said
somebody should make brunch or bowls Oh
use if somebody should make it I said
that already exist no yeah you go it's
branch of all three - Wow make you fancy
okay Adam welcome to make it fancy yeah
I'm getting Andrews leftovers I've got
all I am do it's fresh too you made
leftovers fancy that's what you made
pants ooh that's good the ham is sweet
Holly it's one of the ingredients
yeah no standing right over there
did I make it fancy if I say you didn't
make it fancier do I not have to do the
fancy dance Eva or you have to do the
bass just like I do this you did it
three two won't make you fancy
[Music]
make it fancy but I made a fancy right
yeah yes thank you so much for watching
I hope you make a home if you make it
please like me on Instagram and don't
forget to pass make it fancy
[Music]